so hello everyone and welcome to my talk
on data transformation and exploratory
analysis I'd like to start off here by
asking you guys a few questions so first
how many of you consider yourselves data
scientists okay how many of you spend a
lot of time exploring data great and the
third question how many of you have a
formal process or framework that you use
for doing data exploration okay
excellent you've all come to the right
place
so what I'd like to do in this talk is
tell you a little bit about the process
that I use for exploratory data analysis
in my day to day work and for the few of
you that had a process of your own my
hope is that you see some some
similarities between my approach and
yours and that you take away a couple of
ideas of things that you can incorporate
into your own process and for those of
you that don't already have a process of
your own what I hope you take away from
this talk is an intuitive repeatable
framework for analyzing visualizing and
finding insights in your data but before
I jump into that I'd like to tell you a
little bit about myself so that's me my
name is Tony Ojeda I've been in the
analytics space and more recently in the
data science space for a little over a
decade now I'm the founder of district
data labs which is a data science
research lab and open source
collaborative based in Washington DC and
I got into data science from kind of a
business analytics and Finance
background which is where I acquired my
analytical and quantitative skills and
then I taught myself how to program over
the years in both R and Python and so in
the years that I've been in this field
I've worked with my fair share of
analyst data scientists as well students
learning data science and I've noticed
that particularly during the data
exploration phase of their work I often
see them grasping at straws when it
comes to their approach to finding
insights in the data and so I wanted to
put this presentation together to help
create a more structured path for people
so that they could follow it and view
insight
discovery has a problem break that
problem down into manageable components
and then work toward a solution and so
in this talk we're going to look at an
example of a real data set I'm going to
introduce you to the framework that I
use and then we're going to walk through
the concepts in the framework and use
them on the example data set but before
I do that and jump into the framework
I'd like to provide a little bit more
context talk a little bit about what
data is and how I think about it so data
is basically just encoded information
and information is everywhere everything
that you know everything that you can
think of everything that you encounter
every moment of every day has the
potential to be captured encoded and
therefore turned into data and this
makes our world a very complex web of it
and so we can think of it each data set
that we encounter in our work as just a
slice of this complexity that someone
has put together to communicate
something about the world to either a
human or a machine and so now as humans
we have this built-in ability to deal
with this complexity all around us and
all this information that we're
constantly receiving and the way that we
do this is by organizing things right we
put things in order we group things into
categories we create hierarchical
classifications taxonomies we tag things
now all that stuff and these things help
provide order in structure to the way
that we view the world and they allow us
to be able to take a look at something
recognize the similarities it has to a
group of other things and then identify
its properties it has so that we can be
able to make decisions about it and so
the fact is this ability to create kind
of order out of complexity is built-in
to us is great and we use it all the
time really without ever really thinking
about it and unfortunately that also
includes when we're analyzing data so I
wanted to put together a data
exploration framework that took
advantage of this ability in US and that
would help us make better use of it in
our workflows
and this is what I came up with so the
framework is basically broken down into
two phases
there's the prep phase on top and then
you've got the explore phase and
throughout the presentation we're going
to walk through each of the steps here
and I will point out that you can
technically do the explore phase without
the prep phase but it's really the prep
phase that's going to allow you to do
the exploration well and so I highly
recommend taking the time to kind of go
through the entire thing all right so
the data set that I'm going to be
applying this framework to today is the
Environmental Protection Agency's
vehicle fuel economy data set and I've
included the URL there so anybody that
wants to download it couldn't download
it and this is what the data set looks
like after some flight cleanup all right
and so jumping right into the framework
here the first step in the preface was
to identify a few different things about
our data set so let's go ahead and do
that the first thing that we're going to
identify is the types of information
that are contained in our data and so
just from taking a look at this there's
a few kind of obvious types of
information that really jump right out
at us
we've got vehicle attribute information
in there we've got vehicle manufacturer
information we've got engine information
fuel information all these things right
there's also some additional kind of
maybe not so obvious types of
information that are in our data set so
since we've got the year in there that
each vehicle was made we can take a look
at changes in the data over time in
addition to that there's also
relationship and information in our data
set both in terms of the relationships
between fields and also between entities
and because we have both time and
relationship information we can acquire
information about how those
relationships change over time as well
all right so the next step is to
identify the actual entities that are in
our data and so what exactly do I mean
when I say entities so when I refer to
an entity I'm talking about the
individual analyzable units that are in
a data set in order to conduct the
analysis the entities must be
distinguishable from one another right a
human or a computer needs to be able to
look at them and say this is one this is
another etc and finally entities you
usually have a hierarchical structure
where they're usually able to be
aggregated into the system or the
higher-level entity that they belong to
and so now that we've defined this let's
take a look at the entities in our data
set so here we're starting off at level
one which is the most granular that we
have and that's the year and the
specific model of vehicle and now from
there we can aggregate that up and look
at the year and the model type which is
a little less granular and from there we
have a few different directions that we
can head we got the year and the vehicle
class the year and the make or we can
just strip the year away and keep the
model tied and then finally at level 4
we can aggregate even further to just
the the vehicle classes the years or
what makes to drive that home and
clarify it a little bit further here's
an actual example from the data set so
down at the bottom level which is the
year in the specific model you have a
2016 Ford Mustang with 2.3 liter v4
engine automatic transmission and
rear-wheel drive at level 2 we can roll
things up and take a look at just all
all 2016 Ford Mustangs as one entity
that we're analyzing and then at level 3
you can do the same thing kind of with
all 2016 subcompact cars all 2016 Ford's
or address all Ford Mustangs regardless
regardless of the year they were made
and then it's it's kind of up the
hierarchy from there
and and again so doing this is important
and it'll help you think about all the
different things that you can do with
your data and all the different ways
that you can look at it later on and I
see a lot of people that are new to data
science that don't do this right they
don't think like this and then they miss
things in the data that they should be
catching so I hope this helps to make
that a little bit clearer all right so
the next step in the prep phase is to
review some of the transformation and
visualization methods so that they're
fresh in our heads here and so first up
are the transformation methods so let's
take a look at some of my favorite ways
to transform data here so the first one
I've listed is is filtering which is
basically making the dataset smaller by
either looking at less rose less columns
or both the next one I've listed is
aggregation and disaggregation and this
is basically where you're changing the
levels at which you're analyzing the
data so you're getting either less or
more granular then we have pivoting
which is where you a great by more than
one variable along two axes so along the
rows and along the columns as well and
then the last one I have on here is
graph transformations which is where you
link the entities that you're analyzing
by the things that they have in common
and then examine the connections between
the entities and how they're related to
each other and so by transforming the
data you're ultimately altering the
structure of it which lets you take a
look at it from a bunch of different
perspectives and just like looking at
anything else from several different
perspectives you're gonna learn
something new about it from every way
that you look at it and the awesome
thing about that is that the number of
ways that we can transform the data is
only limited really by our creativity
and our imagination and so this for me
is one of the most exciting things about
working with data right all all the
different things you can do to it and
all the creative ways that you can
transform it
in addition to transforming the data I
also like to go a step further and
visualize it sometimes the
transformations that you perform can be
kind of difficult to interpret visually
and I find that plotting really allows
you to bring the human visual cortex
into your analytical process and usually
makes the insights jump right out at you
and so transformation and visualization
really go hand-in-hand since there's a
multitude of ways to transform the data
there's also a bunch of ways that you
can visualize it I personally like to
keep things fairly easy and so here are
a few of the visualizations that I use
most often and if you you don't know
what a few of these are there's tons of
pictures all right so the last step in
the prep phase is a little more involved
and that's to create additional
categories additional categorical fields
that are going to make our data easier
to transform in it and explore later on
and we're going to do this in three
different ways the first way is
identifying opportunities to create
higher level categories out of the
categorical variables that we currently
have and so imagine here aggregating by
transmission which has 44 unique
categories in our data set and trying to
look at that and analyze that it's going
to be tough and you can have to work
really hard to find any kind of insights
there but if we take a look at the
different categories and find things
that some of them have in common then we
can make it a little bit easier on
ourselves and so in this case the thing
that all 44 values had in common is that
they fall into one of two categories
right either automatic transmission or a
manual transmission and the same thing
with the vehicle class field in our data
set we started off with 34 different
categorical values but I was able to
distill those down into eight categories
which is a lot easier to look at okay so
keep in mind that when you're doing this
you're not overriding the original
categories what you're doing is you're
creating another categorical field
that's allowing you to view the
information at a higher level and so if
you need to drill
to the more granular categories you can
always do that but at least now that
you've done this we have a choice the
next way that that we can create
additional categories for ourselves is
by bidding our continuous variables so
breaking them up into different
categories based on how high or how low
they are and there's um there's there's
multiple ways that you can do this but I
like to use quintiles because it gives
me one middle category and then two
categories that outside of that which
are moderately higher and lower and then
two extreme categories at the ends and I
just find that that's a very kind of an
intuitive way to take a look at things
and to split things up and so here I've
identified four fields in our data that
we could do this with and I've created
quintiles for each one and the final
thing that we're gonna do in this phase
is cluster to create categories out of
the different clusters that the
algorithm finds so there's a few reasons
that I like to use clustering for
creating categories specifically so
first it takes multiple fields into
consideration together whereas the other
kind of categorization methods that we
just looked at only consider one field
at a time it also creates new categories
for you automatically which saves time
versus you having to comb through the
data trying to find patterns then you
can form categories on this will
automatically group all the similar
items together for you and the third
reason I like clustering is because it
sometimes groups things in ways that you
as a human made out may not have thought
of right and I'm generally a big fan of
humans and machines working together but
the question with clustering is always
well how many clusters right and the
answer is usually it depends there's no
real like right answer for this and so
that being said for this purpose I
usually like to keep it to under ten
because otherwise it becomes kind of too
many categories for you to take a look
at and intuitively like distinguish
between and when you're clustering to
create meaningful categories it's key
that you're able to distinguish one from
the other
just like the entities that we discussed
earlier
and so I usually start out with about
eight or ten clusters and then work my
way down until I find some clear
boundaries between the clusters so you
should be able to look at them and
visually distinguish one from the others
and so starting out that's going to look
like this right so I've basically ran
the numerical fields in our data through
a k-means clustering algorithm and had
it group the data into eight clusters
and so just from looking at this you can
tell that we probably have too many
clusters here because clusters three
four and six look a lot alike clusters 0
and 1 are also pretty close and clusters
2 and 5 also look a lot alike as well
and so just judging from the way this
looks I'm willing to bet that we can cut
the number of clusters in half and get
better boundaries so let's take a look
at that all right so here we've reduced
the number of clusters down to 4 and now
the clusters look a lot better don't
they so cluster 0 & 1 kind of look like
polar opposites of each other cluster 2
looks like it's pretty well balanced all
the way across the board and cluster 3
looks like it's kind of halfway between
clusters 0 and cluster 2 and so now we
have a good and so so now we have a good
number of clusters right but it's kind
of hard to remember what clusters 0 1 2
& 3 mean and so the next step I like to
take is to assign descriptive names to
each of the clusters and so here's based
on the field that we were using to
cluster I basically just assigned some
descriptive cluster names to each one
and so now that we have these meaningful
categories our data is in really good
shape and that means that we can move on
to the explore phase
so in this explore phase we're going to
first look at filtering and aggregation
and then we're going to look at
relationships between fields and after
that we're going to move on and look on
look to relationships between the
entities in our data we're going to look
at these things visually we're going to
look at these things over time whenever
possible and we're going to use them to
discover insights in our data and so to
start out here I filtered the data by
year so just for 2016 and I've
aggregated it by vehicle type and here's
what kind of the transformation looks
like and then be accompanying bar chart
and so from this we can see that there's
there's currently significantly more
small cars being made than all the other
cars followed by SUVs and then midsize
cars after that and so once you've done
this once it's pretty easy to change out
the year and get a different historical
perspective and so here's the exact same
aggregation for 1985 this time and so
here
SUV didn't exist yet small cars are even
more popular as we're pickup trucks as
well and and then the next one with
special purpose vehicles which is things
like ambulances ice cream trucks that
kind of thing and so in addition to
being able to change the year here you
can also change out the field that
you're grouping on and so here we come
back to the current year and I plugged
in the engine size quintiles that we
created earlier in the prep phase and I
can do the same thing with the fuel
efficiency categories that we created or
even with the clusters and this is great
but what if we wanted to take a look at
the vehicle manufacturers right let's
say we wanted to know how many models
each manufacturer makes or even which
manufacturer currently has the most
models out there well we can do that as
well by just plugging in the make field
and so here we can see the BMW currently
has more models on the market than all
the other auto manufacturers and by
quite a bit actually
all right so so far we've been looking
at the data at a pretty high level
aggregating up by just a single
categorical variable at a time next
we're gonna go down a level and take a
look at two or more variables at a time
and the way that we're gonna do that is
with pivot tables and so here I've
created a pivot heat map where you have
a row for each fuel efficiency category
and a column for each engine size
category and you can see how many
vehicles fall into each combination of
these and now just like we did earlier
we can slice this by a different year
and easily get a different perspective
so here's what the heat map looks like
for 1985 and so with this approach we're
not just limited to two variables we can
have multiple variables for any of the
axes and it'll show all the different
combinations of values for those
variables by whatever other variables we
want and so in this heat map I've
doubled up on the rows I've got the
engine size and the fuel efficiency
combinations represented by the rows and
then we've added a third variable the
vehicle category across the columns on
the bottom there and so now you can see
a finer level of detail about what types
of cards have what size engines and what
level of fuel efficiency we've added a
little bit more complexity and a little
bit more granularity to how we're
viewing the data here and so if we
wanted to go back to analyzing the
different manufacturers what we can do
is take a look at how the number of
bottles they have on the market is
distributed across the different vehicle
categories so kind of kind of something
like this and now I've got a better
sense of each cup company's current
strategy in terms of the breadth versus
the depth of vehicles that they make so
by taking a look at this we can see that
like the BMW is making a bunch of small
cars more small cars than any other
category and Porsche is also Ford Chevy
and Nissan are kind of going for breadth
they make vehicles in almost every
category Jeep and Land Rover are making
only SUVs Ram is only making pickup
trucks there's a few other companies
that are
only making small cars and then all the
other companies are kind of somewhere in
between there alright so in addition to
looking at these different aggregations
and pivots visually at a given point in
time I also find it very useful to take
a look at how they've changed over time
and so that's what we're gonna do here
next so for example here are our vehicle
categories over time so we can see from
this that small cars are generally
dominated across the board we can also
see the introduction and increase in
popularity of SUV starting in about the
late 90s and we can see the gradual
decline in popularity of pickup trucks
as well and so now from here if we
wanted to we could zoom in and filter
for a specific manufacturer in order to
see how their specific strategy is has
has changed over the years and so here's
the same chart for BMW their vehicle
categories over time and we can see that
they started off making a reasonable
number of small cars and then sometime
in the late 90s they made a decision to
start increasing the types of small cars
that they make and we can contrast that
with a company like Toyota for example
who started out making a lot of small
cars and then made a decision kind of
around the same time
to start making less and less of them
over the years instead shifting their
focus to SUVs and pickup trucks
all right so that's the filter and
aggregate stage the next step in the
explore phase is examining the
relationships between fields in our data
so for looking at the relationships
between variables I like to start off
with a scatter matrix and this kind of
gives me a bird's eye view of all the
relationships and all the fields in my
data set so from this we can see that
there's some kind of more linear
relationships in there this there's also
some more exponential ones as well and
this is great but what's even better is
that we can add another dimension of
insight to this by overlaying a layer of
colors on top of this that represents
for example the clusters that we created
earlier and so here I've overlaid our
clusters and now we can see not only the
relationships but also where the
different cluster boundaries are and how
much overlap there is from one cluster
to the next and once we've got this
colorful bird's-eye view now we can
easily zoom in on anything that looks
interesting to us and so here I've
zoomed in on the engine size versus the
fuel efficiency fields
what the cluster is overlaid and so from
this we can see kind of our very small
are a small very efficient cluster on
the upper left in the purple there
followed by our small moderately
efficient cluster in blue and then our
midsize balanced cluster in red and
finally our large inefficient cluster at
the bottom right there in green and so
here I've clustered the engine size
against the fuel cost so more of a
linear relationship with the clusters
and here the clusters kind of follow the
same progression but this time from the
bottom left to the top right and again
you can do this for any combination of
variables that you had in the scatter
matrix
all right so the third step in our
explore phase is examining relationships
between entities in our data set and the
way that we're going to do that is
through graph analysis so as I said
before graph analysis is gonna allow us
to explore the relationships between
entities and these relationships are
usually based on attributes that the
entities have in common
so the entities we're going to analyze
in our example here is the auto
manufacturers and in this case the
attributes that they have in common are
going to be vehicles with similar
attributes so we're gonna examine how
the different manufacturers relate to
each other and how those relationships
have changed over time now in order to
do this we're gonna have to transform
our data set yet again from the
relational form it's currently in here
into graph form and that's gonna look
like this so here we have two different
companies as make X and make Y and then
we have an edge weight and the edge
weight tells us how many vehicles with
similar attributes the two companies
have in common and so the more vehicles
with similar attributes they have in
common the more alike that the two
companies are gonna be and the stronger
their connection is gonna be and so
looking at the data in this format you
might say there's not much to it and
you're right
but having it formatted like this lets
you create really interesting things
like this and so this is a network
visualization showing the relationships
of the different manufacturers to each
other and from taking a look at this we
can see for example that the companies
that make the most types of vehicles
across the most number of categories are
positioned towards the center of the
network and that's because they're gonna
have more in common with other companies
just as a result of the depth and
breadth of their offerings you can
contrast that with other companies that
have more specialized offerings like RAM
at the very top there or a Land Rover at
the bottom they only make one type of
vehicle and so they have less
connections and they're gonna be
positioned towards the edges so this is
great but taking a look at all this all
at once does make it look a little bit
cluttered and so what I usually like to
do from here
is to filter this down and take a look
at an ego got an ego graph for a
specific node and so I went ahead and I
created a an ego graph for Nissan here
and here you can see that they're now at
the center of the network and you can
also see all the other companies that
they have vehicles in common with and
how those are all connected to each
other so a lot easier to see here at
this point another thing that you can do
with grass is community detection and so
I took our original graph with all the
companies in it and all the connections
and I ran through a community detection
algorithm and it was able to find for
communities and so here I basically just
color-coded a graph based on the
community that each company fell into
and you probably already guessed what's
coming up next and that's taking a look
at how the connections have changed over
time and so in this line graph this
shows the number of edges or connections
for each company over time and again
when you have a lot of nodes in your
graph this intent to look a bit
cluttered also but remember that you can
always filter it down for just the
specific companies that you're
interested in and that's what I've done
here so I've just chosen a handful of
companies and now we can see kind of
more clearly how each of their
connections have changed over time and
converged in recent years
all right so we've done a lot to this
data set in just a short amount of time
and using just a few simple concepts so
let's do a quick review so here's a
picture of the framework as well so we
started off with the prep phase at at
the top there and the first thing we did
was we identified the types of
information and the entities in our data
set then we moved on to reviewing the
different transformation and
visualization methods that are available
to us and then we created additional
categories in our data and we did that
three different ways we did that through
category aggregations we did that by
pinning our continuous variables and we
did that by clustering and then at that
point we were ready to move on to the
explore phase we started off by tuning
the filtrate an aggregate step taking a
look at the bar charts and the pivot
heat maps then we moved on to the
relationships between our fields and
then finally we use graph analysis to
analyze the relationship between our
entities that are in our data we did all
this visually we did all this over time
whenever possible and what do we end up
with at the end of the day so many
insights right I mean just in the short
amount of time that we've been taking a
look at this data set look at all the
insights that we've discovered from it
about one insight per minute on average
which is actually pretty good so we're
not doing too bad here so in wrapping up
I'd like to leave you with a few more
things to think about and in addition to
just the framework I hope that you find
the framework useful but there are a few
other important kind of more understated
things that I really like to call
attention to here at the end so the
first thing is I'd like to encourage you
not to take the data that you're giving
it at face value
right it's it's only really a starting
point and I hope that I've demonstrated
here that the more effort you put into
thinking about the data prepping the
data transforming the data and looking
at the data from different perspectives
the more valuable insights you're going
to find
the second thing I'd like you to
consider is whether or not something
like this can be automated or more
specifically which parts of this can be
automated and how can we do that so my
personal opinion is that there are
definitely some parts of the framework
that can be automated but there are also
other parts where it's very important
and very valuable to have a human and a
human's intuition in the mix there and
that brings me to the last point that I
want to stress and that's the importance
of humans and machines working together
to discover more insights in the data
than either could on their own and I'm
specifically interested in optimizing
the balance between which analytical
tasks a human is better at and which
analytical tasks a computer is better at
and using that to get the best results
possible and if these things that I'm
talking about interest and excite you we
have an open source project called
cultivar at district data labs that
we're starting to build and we'd love to
have your help so thank you very much if
you're interested in collaborating
please get in touch
here's all my contact info I'm gonna be
posting the slides and the code also for
everything that I did in the
presentation on both Twitter and on
LinkedIn as well so please check me out
there right